you had a crackhead father and your and
your mom you sexually abused you and you
got stabbed cool let me show you this
kid who actually had that exact same
thing and he won if you've got debt or
have to put a roof over your head or
somebody else then you work whatever job
is paying that but I'm asking you what
are you doing from 6:00 p.m. to midnight
but I think that if you're in the game
just for the fine things in life for the
bottles and the models and the private
planes I think you're gonna lose once or
nganimate for today let's learn from one
of the best get very nice advice on
complainings work ethic in happiness
mentor me Gary also if you want to know
what Gary others have to say about
building confidence check out my 254
series it's free in description below
the reason people don't put themselves
in a position to fail the reason people
aren't patient is they value other
people's opinions too much
[Music]
you
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one make no excuses and this is my
biggest point to everybody this is why I
don't allow complaining and yelling for
people that want to with me because no
matter what I'm gonna point to somebody
who had the same exact said oh what you
had a crackhead father and you and your
mom you sexually abused you and you got
stabbed cool let me show you this kid
who actually had that exact same thing
and he won like what we're talking about
right now is the reason I win I'm not
worried about the little details this is
all macro blueprint strategy mental
strategy no matter what we say right now
Pete I'm gonna show you somebody who
grew up with the same exact situation
have different outcomes and so for
really everybody's dwelling on their
shortcoming the bottom line is no matter
where you start
everybody has paths to winning and
losing for me the best move is to take
control your no matter how tough you are
right now get rid of loser friends and
family introduce yourself to positivity
and winners and watch how it plays out
softly you need to ask yourself tonight
why it's more interesting to dwell and
complain and come up with excuses than
actually be happy I'll save you time
your mom you up
so cool right or your dad or your older
brother or some circumstance here's my
big thing I'm looking around and even
for the geezers in here you're all
living for another 50 years minimum
there's people in here but dude I know I
know you're like awesome right cuz when
you were kids you're like 60 now now
right now but you know it's crazy now it
is not like how many of you here under
30 all of you outside of like devastate
by that scale almost all of you get to a
hundred hundred ten easy that's nuts
you're you're freaking out you turn 30
and you were living for another 95 years
like I don't have mice together I'm like
you started three muscle I talked about
hustle here's why if I looked at all of
us right now and everybody behind these
cameras or reading this article and said
get smarter more talented I want you to
get more talented that's very tricky
that's unbelievably ideological advice
if I said look two extra hours of work
actually has an impact on your success
if that's what you're trying to achieve
that's practical yeah you don't have to
but it's controllable work ethic is
controllable being born with talent is
not roll over for grind if you've got
debt or have to put a roof over your
head or somebody else then you work
whatever job is paying you that but I'm
asking you what are you doing from 6:00
p.m. to midnight and if you have to go
build slowly your portfolio your Shopify
store your Instagram account your
YouTube channel
your content like like wouldn't you be
pumped if I told you for the next four
years it's tough and you don't watch as
much Netflix and sports and hanging out
but then you get to live happy for
the rest of your life everybody in
theory would sign up for that the
reality is a lot of people don't want to
grind for four years like people don't
like pain it's why most people don't
have six-packs I mean that I mean that
there's a lot of people here who want to
be a better shape you just don't want to
workout you just don't want to eat well
it provides love the gays what are the
qualities that you think made for a true
and a successful entrepreneur what's
important she or he has to love the game
for me a purebred entrepreneur she or he
loves the journey not the stuff you know
one of the things I struggle with in the
current state of entrepreneurship is a
lot of people want the vacations the
watches you know even the in the context
of this you guys have such an incredible
imagery I think it's remarkable
who doesn't want fine things in life
yeah but I think that if you're in the
game just for the fine things in life
for the bottles and the models and the
private planes I think you're gonna lose
and it definitely is not my definition
of an entrepreneur my definition of an
entrepreneur is somebody who can't live
without doing their thing and trying to
create literally suffocated rule number
six find happiness you gotta figure out
what makes you happy on your turn
that's okay though that's that's I think
your dwelling and putting more
compounded pressure on yourself for
something that every 21 year old is
living the only 21 year olds know
just at least be a goal like sneakers so
you can have your shoes on to them for
the race car that's fine but I'm telling
you make it the process of life not some
sort of goal even the Jets things
upfront I want to try to buy the job
what it really means is I love the
process so much that I want to do
something so big
really so I could do the process buying
the Jets I want the process of trying it
you got to fall in love with doing
something every day not what the gonna
get you or what the goal is that
arbitrary stuff there's being serious
just what do you like to do do it and
what and eat on it and if that's being
an artist and you can only eat like a
McDonald's everyday then you're good you
got to fall in love with the thing you
gotta get that place number seven the
last one before a very special bonus
clip is love the climb I was at the top
of the wine game and I left because I
won I didn't want to do it anymore
and went into marketing where everyone
liked the first article written about me
was like this guy huh
wine Twitter I think the article in the
big advertising magazine was Twitter boy
is what they called me Twitter boy
thinks he's gonna come and win Madison
Avenue hahahahaha they're not laughing
anymore you know and even this game now
I can already feel it I'm like oh man
three four or five years from now this
thing's a wrap I'm gonna be the guy so
I'm gonna have to start selling oranges
or something you know I got to figure
you know I've been have to figure
something out because I lose like I'm
about to climb back to sports I grew up
a die-hard Yankees Jets Rangers Knicks
fan the Yankees and Rangers won their
championships I literally stopped
watching them
Nixon Jets are gonna take me a minute
you know but like but like I'm just
about because I just love the climb like
even like back to sports does that I
think it's great analogy I'll turn on a
random game I need to know who the
underdog is that's my team I'm just
about to climb you know like to me when
I see a kid wearing a Steph Curry Jersey
and that kid lives in New York I think
that kids soft
I mean it he's he's using somebody
else's success to make himself feel good
I think the biggest tell of a losing
person is wearing a jersey outside your
own city now I've got two very special
bonus tips I'm Gary on how to work hard
and smart as well as love the process
that I think you're gonna enjoy but
before that it's time for the
three-point landing questions time to
move from just watching another video
and taking action in your life for
business here we go question number one
what does happiness look like for you
number two what are you gonna do today
to hustle and grind and number three
what excuse are you going to stop
telling yourself how much time do you
spend a month you said those four things
how much time do you actually spend on
it in a day zero
sometimes I assume in a week how much do
you spend two hours great now is the
most important part of this meeting
how many hours do you sleep at night
great so I love the way you said it I
have to have seven so if I wanted to say
go to six so that you pick up five
you're gonna say to me Gary I have to
have seven right now let's go somewhere
else I have to know what you're doing
the other 17 hours I would bet the house
that we can find an hour every day I'm
guaranteeing because you might be
working all 17 hours but you might not
be working on something smarter than
spending an hour a day on the thing that
you're talking about do you understand
that's I mean look that's the answer the
answer is time you know people talk
about working hard and working smart the
answer is only both you have to work
hard and smart based on your ambition if
you want to build a business for
yourself that is like a 1% life most
people understand what building a
business for yourself is it's very
special
it's very special trying to build a
business for yourself everybody's doing
now pulling it off
trying to play basketball everybody can
try being an NBA player trying to be a
rapper or a singer everybody's doing
pulling it off trying to be a footballer
and actress got it so you're trying
great pulling it off is hard it takes
everything time and smarts you need
seven I'm glad you said it that way
because this makes this piece of content
more valuable
it's the 17 other Alice
I'll give you an example a lot of people
drive to work for 45 minutes if they
took a bus for an hour and 15 minutes
they would save money and get more work
done
but do you have the humility to take the
bus force to drive in your car I've
never done anything financial a lot of
good things have happened to me that has
remotely hit my radar more than the year
I made a hundred thousand a year I would
argue that if you really knew everything
about me and you read it all every
action I ever did you would look me in
the face and ask me why do you sabotage
yourself in business and financials
environments and I would tell you that
deep down subconsciously I loved it so
much that I just want it to happen
forever and so for me making it is is a
four you know it's just there is that's
what that's what blows me away about
somebody who's like I just need to make
a million bucks and I'm gonna go to
Jamaica right or or like I I don't have
that I don't have that in my head I just
want to play forever and that's why I'm
trying to get people to understand the
process because I it is very clear to me
that people that are in love with their
craft and process can win and that's why
I'm trying to change the conversation
around how much money you need to be
happy because it doesn't work like I
just know unbelievable amounts of data
of how many people have lots of money
how many people don't have lots of money
by our standards and how happy they are
and it doesn't take a lot of money to be
you know to be alive in society it's
about what you spend it money on
if you want to learn how to make $1,000
a week garage sale flipping with your
Eevee go check out their video right
there next to me I think you'll enjoy it
continue to believe and I'll see you
there if I was really doing this right
beside me I'd make a thousand a week
easy